[Music]
finally the holidays are over this topic
finally I think we've got some time for
this inshallah in the topic I wanted to
discuss today anyway but I received a
message from a sister and she said
obviously she was getting to know this
bomber for my region everything was
going well until the family found out
that she is a divorce sister now this is
a big big problem with Anoma sisters who
are divorced are being looked up down
upon like I'm they even going to mention
anything in a very disgusting way and
they're human beings and we get these
messages and assistance in what am I
supposed to do I got married it didn't
work out other overlock but what am I
gonna do I'm being rejected just because
I'm divorced they actually they said
look we don't want to know you they
totally cut off the sister
just because she's divorced if you can
give us the answer inshallah and give an
example of time of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him how the Sahaba marry
divorce systems etc if you can really
tackle this issue please brother Ali
you've actually touched a chord the
reason is I don't need to give you an
example of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam my
companions can equalize he knows can you
hear me okay sorry I don't need to give
you an example of the Companions when I
can talk about the prophet sallallaahu
salaam himself and I hope the families
will be listening to this and like I say
we haven't mentioned names so the
benefit will be to thousands of people
and before I say that sometimes when I
tweet or when I write something when I
put up a post on Facebook and so on
people say it's like you knew what I was
going through I know I didn't I'm just
being a real human being that's all I
know what I'm going through
that's what it is and I know what a few
people are going through so everyone
goes through similar things because
we're all human beings you have a house
you eat a few times a day you go out you
earn etc etc let's go
back to what you were saying muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam and i'm
addressing those who treat divorced
women badly or those who look down upon
them all those who don't want to marry
them just because they're divorced who
did he marry himself number one the
woman he chose and he agreed to marry
and he had his children with and he
loved and he continued to say even after
she passed away that you know what I
miss her and he used to be kind to her
relatives even after she passed away was
khadija bint a co-editor of the allahu
ana she was divorced she was married
before there are narrations that
actually make mention of two men that
she was married to one after the other
and some say one that's besides the
point but what's confirmed is she was
not a virgin so to speak she was married
before the Prophet Allah Allah agreed
she was much older the Prophet SAW said
I'm agreed subhanAllah why would he do
that
thereafter all his wives were either
widows or divorced all of them besides
it is share of the Allahu and half the
only one why I think that answers the
question the ignorance of these people
regarding their own prophet the one whom
they declare their entry into Islam with
in terms of the statement ashhadu anna
muhammadan abduhu wa rasuluhu they don't
even know who is that muhammadan abduhu
wa rasuluhu sallallahu alayhi wa sallam
they haven't even they probably know he
was married to so and so's but they've
never paused to think about it may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala make it easy for all
those who are divorced to marry again
don't give up don't give up there are
some good guys out there Jala quite a
few of them I see them here this
afternoon mashallah and the other way as
well if you've had a bad experience my
brothers it doesn't mean it's the end of
the world you can get up and each other
you can get married by the will of allah
subhanahu wata'ala similarly may we make
dua that those who are not married at
all you know you might be
thinking you've forgotten us no we
haven't may allah subhanahu wata'ala
assist you and guide you the point we're
raising here is don't judge people don't
think they were bad just because they're
divorced and one more thing when they're
divorced you are bound to hear rumors we
live in an age of whatsapp have you come
across that if you live in the age of
whatsapp you can imagine what's happing
well all day and all night
people are just saying things and they
they just you know forwarding anything
and everything we love gossip let's be
honest we love it we we actually cause
the spreading of gossip just by
forwarding messages this is why I said
in a few days ago when I was speaking
somewhere else that you know what you
need to do delete the message and reply
the person to say please don't send me
this type of gossip again but you are
bound to hear bad things because
everyone wants to prove a point I've
seen a few people who are so good that
after the divorce when you ask them what
went wrong they say that was between me
and her and you know what she's the
mother of my children I don't want to
say anything bad it's okay she's loved a
lovely person and we didn't get along
well llahi that man or that woman
deserves the mercy of Allah because they
are being merciful upon someone else so
be careful when you've been through a
divorce and I know now it's about 60% of
marriages end up in divorce that's the
statistic that I last read and in in the
Maldives they said it was 90 percent may
Allah forgive us but I do know that's
happening be careful don't try and prove
who was right and wrong that's it leave
it and if you really need to tell
someone because you're now getting
married again people say can I ask you
what went wrong you have the right to
remain silent and to say listen trust me
or it's okay I don't need to marry you
or you want to say you know what really
this went wrong and that went wrong the
sad reality is things would actually
become even worse may Allah forgive us
I'm so sorry to take so long to answer
Erica laughing may Allah bless you
that's it we're finished I think we can
leave now
Salam alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh
I want the same treatment Lee hey give
me one I'm sorry
subscribe you should shoot